داخل احد اقسام الرعايه المركزه في هذه
المستشفى يرقد السيد محمد محب المجني عليه
الذي تم الاعتداء عليه من احد الكلاب
المفترسه لتصبح قصته حديثا المصريين خلال
الايام الماضيه تفاصيل القصه تبدا من هذا
المنتجع الراقي حيث هاجم كلب الجيراني غير
المكمم او المقيد المجني عليه وولده ومزق
اوطارا واعصابا في القدم واليد ليتم نقله
للمستشفى واجراء عمليات جراحيه ويدخل
بعدها في غيبوبه التحريات اثبتت ان الكلب
كان قد سبق وعقل احد الجيران قبل فتره
التقينا زوجه المجني عليه التي طالبت
بضروره وضع تشريعات لمنع تكرار هذا النوع
من الحوادث المشرع المصري وكل الدول في
العالم اي دوله سواء عربيه او غير عربيه
احنا لها هنستنى ناس تانيه يحصل لها نفس
الموقف اللي انا فيه برضو عايزه اقول
لحضرتك انا لسه في موقف ان انا قدري غير
محتوم يعني ممكن جوزي ربنا ينجيه في ناس
تانيه ما بتوصلش لمرحله دي النيابه العامه
امرت بحبس صاحب الكلب على ذمه القضيه اهم
جزء في النيابه في بين النيابه العامه
الجزء جنب المعلومات في جزء مهم جدا
بيخاطب فيه المجتمع انت من حقك وحريتك انك
انت تربي ولكن هذه الحريه لازم تكون
منضبطه هذه الحريه يجب ان تكون
بتؤمن حياه الاخرين ما ينفعش انك تؤذي
الاخرين يعني الراجل اللي في المستشفى ده
بين الحياه والموت برلمانيون طالبوا
بضروره من
ع استلقاع التواصل الاج اي مطالب بضروره
وضع ضوابط جديده لحيازه الكلاب وسن قوانين
تقضي بالسجن لاصحاب الكلاب التي تقوم
بايذاء الاخرين المشكله انه قانون
العقوبات الحالي ما فيهوش نص يقول ان لما
كلب يعض حد يتحبس 24 ساعه او ساعه او
اتنين او سنه او اثنين او ثلاثه لذلك
التشريعات المقدمه والمقترحات المقدمه
المجلس النواب بتناقش ان يكون في نص محدد
على مثل هذه الافعال وغيرها من الافعال
اللي بتكون منسوبه الى كلب يحدث اصابه
بالغير هذه الحادثه القت الضوء على نوع
جديد من القضايا فالكلاب التي تتخصص في
حمايه البيوت واصحابها قد تتحول الى جنات
وقد تتسبب في سجن اصحابها احمد عثمان
العربيه القاهره